want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level talent at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only mel robbins
enjoy
if you're in a situation
where
you should do something
and the excuses roll in
you only have five seconds before the
excuses win that's it
and it has to do with how your brain is
designed and so
i started seeing this five second window
everywhere
everywhere you walk into a networking
meeting and the five second window is
right there because you look around and
you see all these people you should talk
to and you feel yourself freeze
five four three two one and you can
start walking
if you're trying to sell something the
five second window is always there
because you either have a phone you need
to pick up and make a phone call or you
have a person you need to talk to but
instead of doing it that five second
window's right there and the excuses
roll in and then you're not doing it yep
and so
it's almost like we talk ourselves out
of it right after five seconds like why
not to do it all and then it's even more
sophisticated than that is which which
is what i discovered and what's more
sophisticated about it is that
you have two modes to your brain you
have the prefrontal cortex which is the
mode of your brain it's the front part
of your brain that does all your
strategic planning your decision making
your
not all your decision making that's
wrong
it does your intentional decision making
conscious decision making
it's what you're using when you're
acting with courage it's what you're
using when you are learning anything new
if you've ever taken a standardized test
when you walk out of a standardized test
what do you have you have a freaking
headache because you've been using this
part of your brain
that's the one part the other part is
the interior part of your brain which
automates everything it's where
self-doubt is it's where habits are it's
where automated decision-making is it's
where every negative [ __ ]
that we do it's stuck right here so what
the five-second rule is actually doing
on a very sophisticated level is it's
switching off this part and awakening
the part that gives you control and so
the problem with our excuses if you want
to get into the brain science is that if
you start to think
and you start to think i feel tired or i
don't want to or i'm too stressed out or
now is not the right time
that becomes automatic
and it gets encoded right here
so part of the problem with our excuses
is that when you stop and think and
hesitate you trigger your brain to
automatically talk you out of it
that's the problem it's not the excuses
it's that your brain has done it over
and over and now it takes over right so
i invented the world's um most powerful
cheat code for the brain
one night when i was drunk sitting in my
living room watching television i think
the work that we all have to do
every single one of us whether you
bulldoze
whether you people please
whether you avoid conflict
whether you're impulsive
whether you uh yo-yo your decisions
uh
whatever it is that is your pattern
you know you the the constant trashing
yourself
i think the the the journey of your
whole life
is figuring out how to truly
like
and love yourself if you
are afraid of disappointing people
if you're afraid that you're not good
enough
you may catch that in one area of your
life but as your life gets bigger and as
you change it'll creep in in other areas
and one way that those patterns where
you don't think you deserve it or you
don't think you're good enough or you're
terrified of disappointing people
comes into play is when you start to
expect the worst
and so
catch it that's the first step you can't
break your pattern unless you see it
and then you're gonna replace it and
what i'm gonna start doing is i've got
this little app on my watch you can set
it on your phone
where
every like three hours it reminds me to
breathe and i notice the second that the
alarm goes off i've been holding my
breath
and so you can set a little alarm in
your phone megan's laughing you can set
a little alarm in your phone that just
says saver it's a reminder to take a
minute you can make it say take a minute
take a minute look around comp your
compliment yourself on what's going
right because
expecting the worst is something you
taught yourself to do guess what you can
teach yourself to take a minute
and to savor what's going right and the
more you force yourself to do it the
more it'll become a habit it comes back
to the core message that i always have
for you no matter what's happening
around or to you you hold the power
because you always have the power to
have an honest conversation you always
have the power to discuss how things are
impacting you you always have the power
to make requests and you certainly have
the power to draw boundaries and you
also have the power by the way if the
culture gets worse and worse or you just
are tired of it because it's not
changing to go find a different job
the power is always in you and i think
that's something that's so important to
constantly remind yourself i get that i
don't like where i am but what could i
do to change it
how can i change how i think about this
and
i'm telling you right now you know this
the second you start changing how you
think about a situation the situation
changes the second you start changing
how you think about what your options
are you start to see them the second you
stop thinking that you're stuck or that
you're a victim and you start thinking
about how you solve something you start
to see solutions and so the answer is
always in you you have this behavior
pattern where you get angry you have
this behavior pattern where you snap you
have this behavior pattern where you
yell and you get upset and you make
people wrong and you don't mean to
if you are somebody who's ever said to
yourself i wish i could stop yelling or
i wish i i i i could just snap i could
stop snapping
this video is absolutely
okay and the reason why is i explained
this research that was so
mind-blowing for me
it's called ghosts in the nursery
a lot of the patterns that you have
that you don't have control over
are patterns from your childhood
and they are there because when you were
a kid
you experienced people in your life that
were tense
did you ever have a parent that was a
yeller
did you ever have a teacher that was a
yeller or a coach that was a yeller and
secretly in your little kid body
whenever your mom or dad would yell or
your coach would yell or your teacher
would yell or your grandmother or
grandfather would yell you would feel
tense right
you would feel nervous you would feel on
edge of course that's how we all feel
right well here's the reason why
you might have an issue like i used to
have an issue where i would yell at my
kids and then i'd feel terrible about it
i'd snap at my husband and then i'd feel
terrible about it psychologist and then
i would say to myself i'm not doing that
again i'm not doing that again but i
wouldn't have the ability to end it
psychologists call this ghost in the
nursery
it means that any situation where you
start to feel
tense or you start to feel stressed out
guess what happens your body remembers
what it was like when you were little to
feel tense and stressed out and what
were the adults doing around you when
you felt that way
they were snapping
they were yelling and now here you are
repeating the pattern
and you don't know why and you feel
guilty
and i'm explaining this to you because
it wasn't until i thought holy cow like
i know i don't want to snap at my
husband i know i don't want to take my
anger from work out on my family why
can't i stop this
that's the reason why it's because it's
a pattern that you remember from being a
kid that the adults around you were
snapping or yelling or being mean
any time and when they were you felt
tense and stressed out so now that
you're an adult when you're tense and
stressed out you repeat the behavior
that you witnessed crazy right so how do
you stop it well the first step to
stopping anything is to actually
understand what you're dealing with
now that you know you're dealing with a
pattern
now all you need to do is basically say
okay i'm going to put a practice in
place that's going to interrupt this
pattern what's the practice well a
really good one is
um
before you walk in the house at the end
of the day if you're stressed out take
five
take five deep breaths
like reset your mood reset your energy
before you walk in the house and you'll
be surprised by how much nicer you are
to the people around you
another thing that um
that uh
you can do and this one's not so fun
is you can train your
partner your kids your roommates your
family that if you're trying to get a
hold of how you bring stress home you
can train them to say to you hey
don't take your work stress out on me
when somebody that you care about says
that to you it's a humbling experience
and the person that says it the most in
my life is my son oakley your uh the
youngsters seem to love to cross-check
the adults so be careful with taking
that advice
i know
that in this next chapter that i
consciously create i want to have more
fun
i want to i really wanna love the
process yeah i don't wanna make it so
hard on myself and be gripping
everything so tight
and it's really easy for me to see it in
other people because i know what it
feels like in here
i'm working hard to break the patterns
that still hold me back and the big one
that holds me back is um bulldozing
that's the it's it's it's literally when
i start to feel
any level of tension this is
particularly true in my marriage um i'm
married to a saint thank god chris
robbins meditates every morning it's the
only reason why we've lasted 26 years
um it's how he puts up with me when i
feel
my like whatever emotion rise i
immediately raise my voice
it's how i assert power in the
relationship
and i am so committed louis
to
breaking that pattern wow and being a
more fun person to be around and a
kinder person to be around first of all
stop talking about passion
stop talking about launching a business
okay
when you think about it too big
it will paralyze you
if you're lucky and you're in a position
where
your bills are getting paid
and you have the luxury of being able to
try to think about what you want to do
in this next chapter
um here's where i want you to start
i want you to start with what energizes
you now how ironic is that given that
i'm speaking at the energetic women's
conference here in indianapolis today
why am i saying energizes here and what
do i talk what am i talking about when i
say energize
when i say energizes you
i'm asking you what is it that you're
curious about
what is it that you feel so
expanded you feel energized you feel
kind of excited whenever you're doing it
you're in a phase when you're just
trying to figure out what's your next
move
of just paying attention to your
curiosity paying attention to the things
that interest you the truth is
passion is just energy
if you're passionate about something it
means you're energized when you do it so
let's reverse engineer this and let's
just
ask yourself a simple question
what are you curious about what
energizes you and if you allow yourself
to explore things that energize you
you my friend will start to
find the clues about what it is that you
should and could be doing because all
the research says that if you're doing
something that you like
if you're doing something that you're
curious about you're not only going to
enjoy it you're going to be really good
at it because if you like doing it
you'll spend more time doing it which
means you're going to get better at it
you know sometimes when the dream is so
big
the fact that it's so big becomes
paralyzing
because you think about where you are
right now and you think holy cow that
thing that i really want
i don't even like how do you even start
when the dream is so big
so here's what we're going to do today
we're going to shrink it down because
you know me i am all about simplicity
i'm all about making sure that the
advice works for you because if it
doesn't work for you you're not going to
do it and i'm all about switching how
you think about things huh making this
smaller
and making it something that i'm
learning about rather than doing and
launching and
that somehow thinking about it
differently frees up the ability to get
started if i get you to start doing that
and you do this every day for 10 or 15
minutes which you absolutely can guess
what's going to happen
you're going to feel momentum you're
going to feel like you're working on it
you're going to meet people that are
interested in it you're going to learn
things that are going to lead to the
next thing that you need to learn and
you will have mastered the art of
getting started and by doing something a
little bit every day you're also going
to master the art of continuing to keep
going and from there it'll snowball i
promise you i promise you you see you're
only ever running against yourself
there's room for all of us there's room
for you to do the same thing there's
room for you to write that book there's
room for you to do those makeup
tutorials there's room for you to launch
that restaurant there's room for you to
start your singing lessons there's room
for you to write that song it is normal
and it is going to happen to you all the
time that you're going to see people
that seem to block out the sun whenever
they make an announcement because
they're that big and that amazing i
don't want you to allow yourself to
shrink when somebody else is doing
something that is
similar to what you want to do you
remember that thing we used to do as
kids where you go
actually you can give yourself affection
i think you know how i have this habit i
have this habit of always high-fiving
myself in the mirror i send myself into
the day go get a mel
that's a form of affection you can show
yourself love through words and through
gifts and through actions because love
is a verb and that's the most important
thing to think about when you think
about practicing self love and
developing habits around self-love
so love is a verb what are the actions
and habits and thoughts that you would
have
when you think about how you treat or
speak to somebody you love self-love is
about giving yourself all the things
that you freely give to the people that
you love
and what's so awesome is that when you
learn and start practicing
how to love yourself
it expands your capacity to love other
people more deeply because you can't
give other people
something that you don't give to
yourself and i know you're like whoa i
love other people but you don't truly
love other people if you can't love
yourself
because there's a part of you that
doesn't feel worthy and so you got to
practice this stuff and it's everything
here are some ways that i practice first
of all if
someone you loved were struggling
what would you recommend they do in
terms of how they take care of
themselves first of all you got to get a
good night's sleep that's a form of
self-love
put good food in your body that's a form
of self-love
take time for yourself every day that's
a form of self-love moving your body and
exercising that's a form of self-love
the biggest form of self-love for me
is not criticizing myself so when i
catch myself criticizing myself trashing
myself beating myself up i kick
that
noise and garbage out of my head and i
replace it with something that i would
say to somebody that i love instead of
focusing on the things that are going
wrong
i kick that thought out of my mind and i
focus on the things that are going right
another form of self-love for me is i'm
constantly
soothing and reassuring myself
mel
hey i know it's challenging right now
but this is preparing you for something
mel i know you're nervous but um
you got this
you can face this and notice i'm using
my name mel
study after study has come out that when
you talk to yourself and use your own
name
it has a much deeper impact on you you
have the experience of almost having
someone else be saying it it lands
deeper and it's also through gifts i
also give myself the gift of buying
flowers every time i go to the grocery
store i started doing that a few years
ago i love flowers i was always waiting
for somebody else to give them to me and
it dawned on me why the hell don't i
just buy it for myself
and so i do
and you'd be surprised
three four five bucks you can always
find a small little bouquet at a grocery
store stick it on your desk it's a
reminder
that you love yourself remember love is
a verb just treat yourself how you would
treat somebody that you love and
practice it and you'll get better and
better at it i am in the middle of um
working on my next book it's called the
high five habit
i
believe with all of my heart and being
that every man woman child person
grandparent everybody
should
infuse their days with habits of
celebration and self-confidence
and the fastest and easiest and most
science-backed way
to
quickly start to change how you see
yourself
is by adopting a simple habit of
high-fiving your reflection in the
mirror every single morning
now i know exactly what you're thinking
are you serious mel robbins that is the
stupidest thing i've ever heard in my
entire life
i know
i know i know it sounds dumb but the
reason why your first instinct when you
think about waking up whether in your
robe or your underwear your pjs or your
birthday suit and walking into that
bathroom and having a moment with
yourself and raising your hand and
high-fiving yourself is because your
self-confidence is in the gutter
you believe some garbage about yourself
you think you're a bad person or you're
unworthy or you're ugly or nobody likes
you or how about this one this was the
story of my life i have [ __ ] up my
life
so badly
i might as well just flush it down the
toilet
you have some narrative in your mind
that is so negative that when you look
in the mirror you see somebody worth
trashing
you see what's wrong you pick apart your
appearance and i want to reverse that
because here's the deal about
self-confidence
self-confidence begins with you
you
realize the word self is in there right
i can't give you confidence i didn't
give you a little boost i can give you
tools i can
encourage you
but confidence is forged in fire
it's something that's within you and
here's the thing i want you to realize
about confidence
you are a confident person
that's why you miss feeling that way you
can only miss what you know
you've just been blocked from the
feeling of it
and wherever you are right now in your
life i'm telling you confidence is in
there you just gotta figure out how to
tap into it and you've been building
confidence all along by the way
every time that you have fallen on your
face or you've tried something and
failed or you've gone out and thought
you found the love of your life and then
your heart's broken and then you pick
yourself up again and then you dust
yourself you're building confidence the
entire time because confidence is not
built on the high days
confidence is built on the low ones
confidence is built when you are
struggling because when you see yourself
go for something and fall when you see
yourself try and get knocked down when
you see yourself stand back up after
getting abused or traumatized or
discriminated against and moving ahead
you are building
this reserve within yourself where you
know you can rely on yourself you know
you can face hard things and you can
keep moving forward you know you have
your own back so it's in there your life
has been helping you build it now you've
got to just dig in and tap into it and
use it to shut that critic up in your
head
so the way you're going to do that is
every morning i'm not kidding you're
going to raise your hand in the mirror
and high-five yourself look at how many
people are doing this
you're not the only one for five
mornings in a row i want you to high
five yourself
and when you do this i want you to use
the hashtag
high five challenge you know what's
happening when you raise your hand up in
the mirror
you are taking the lifetime positive
association that you have with cheering
for other people believing in other
people
uh celebrating other people
saying let's go to other people
and you are marrying that positive
association
with your reflection we are pulling into
boston college for our daughter's
graduation from college it feels like
we just dropped her off here four years
ago
a week ago it is insane how fast time
goes isn't it chris
it is
almost disturbing it's disturbing and so
i always get really weepy and emotional
on big milestone days
because you become so present to how
quickly your life is passing you by
and the only advice that i have for
myself or anybody else in this moment is
just be
in it
be present for it all
the ups the downs every day just be in
it
um
because you are going to blink your eyes
and
your life's gonna be over i mean
literally i don't mean to be like morose
about it but it's true and we
spend so much energy wishing things
would pass wishing that something would
be over wishing that
this moment would change and i'm telling
you right now your life is the greatest
school you will ever attend
every day is uh teaching you something
every day is a lesson
and uh the lesson right now is that we
should have showed up earlier because
the traffic is very big
if you look at
human development we're the only species
that literally can't survive without
another human being taking care of you
and so we are biologically
hard-wired to bond with other people and
that is the ver from the very beginning
of when you come out
bonding with somebody else and making
sure they pay attention to you is your
survival imperative so you are born
needing somebody else and i think what
ends up happening is there's never that
kind of clean
break or pass off between needing your
parents to take care of you needing your
friend's approval to fit in to truly
having ownership over giving yourself
what you didn't get giving yourself what
you needed and that's the piece that
i've been doing a lot of during the the
great pause is slowing down because so
much of my busyness
was fueled by uh you know praise me love
me am i doing enough
you know please tell me i'm doing okay
okay i can breathe now i'm okay now
and when i slow down and maybe it's a
function of the anxiety that's when
things get scary because that's when
you've really got to be with yourself
the reason why it's so important to
start with a friend cleanse and i'm sure
a lot of you how many of you heard that
you thought oh my god getting rid of
people oh boy oh boy i'm gonna cleanse
these friends
yes and no
a friend cleanse is critical because the
single most influential thing around you
are the people that you hang out with
and if you have relationships that are
toxic
if you have relationships that cause
guilt if you have relationships that are
creating drama in your life if you have
relationships that are not equitable
guess what
that's creating the overwhelm that's
creating unhappiness that's
keeping you doubting yourself if you
have friends that um have bad habits
guess what that's making it really
really hard for you to change your
habits for the good now i got fired from
a job i was really excited about
what should i do
excellent question first of all how many
of you have ever been fired from a job
yep
yep i've been fired from a job and let
me tell you something it's a kick in the
teeth doesn't it there is nothing that
feels worse
in the moment than being brought into a
conference room
and being let go and then how bad does
it blow to pack up your stuff and to
leave it stings it is terrible it is
humiliating there is nothing around it
there's nothing around that feeling even
if it's a job that you can't stand
even if it's a job where you've been
looking for another job even if you know
in your heart that this is the biggest
blessing in disguise because you didn't
really like it there you still want to
be the one to rip off the band-aid don't
you you want to be the one to walk and
be like guess what people i found a
different job i'm out of here so when
they beat you to the punch and they tell
you the truth that this isn't working
it's not working for them it's not
working for you and now it's time for
you to leave it is still a kick in the
teeth so i want to be
clear about something
feeling down
feeling embarrassed feeling angry
about how it was handled even if they
handled it in the way that is legal that
is normal
it's normal because
it blows to be rejected and that's
exactly what happens to you emotionally
when you get fired from a job i get that
because boy oh boy have i been there i
have been fired from jobs that i
actually liked i have been fired from
jobs that i needed and i have been fired
from jobs that i
viscerally hated
that i was physically sick going to work
every morning i hated it so much and it
still stinks when you're fired so here's
what i want you to do when you're fired
i want you to really
just relish in how much it stinks
for i don't know an hour
no more than 24 hours you get to milk
this puppy for free you know a free
dinner from your pals at night you get
to milk this and complain about it to
all your friends for 24 hours and then
guess what you got to stop complaining
about it you got to stop thinking about
it because you don't have a choice
anymore the job is over and i don't want
you looking back i want you looking
forward now before you look forward
though i want you to do one of the
signature things that we talk about all
the time and what is that
i want you to look for the message in
the mess
what is it that you learned about
yourself
or about
a job or a boss or a
or a kind of work
that you need to make sure you
understand the message of the mess
because when you get the emotion out of
the way guess what you always see about
a job or a breakup
that happens
you always see that that was exactly
what was supposed to happen that that
job that that person that that manager
that that focus that that was holding
you back and you were just too scared to
take the leap you were too worried about
finances you were worried about how it
looked i've been there i get it but you
need to see the message in the mess
because i don't want you to make the
mistake and step into the exact same
thing or the exact same type of job or
the exact same management situation that
didn't work the first time because part
of the reason why jobs don't work is
it's not a fit
you see people get fired for a lot of
reasons some of the reasons why people
get fired is because the companies are
not doing well and in that case you want
to thank your lucky stars that you're
getting out now so that you can find
something better if it's not a fit
that's a more nuanced reason to get
fired but let me tell you something if
it's not a fit for the company
it wasn't a fit for you either
and so look for the message in the mess
what are you gonna learn about this
situation whether there was a skill gap
and you need to
bring your skills up to speed so that
you're not floundering your next job or
maybe it was a personality gap that you
accepted something that in your heart
you knew wasn't right but you took it
because you had to or because you felt
insecure don't make that mistake again
you know that um
wave that you feel or your tongue gets
numb or you get tightness in your cheeks
or you freeze
you know when that happens
based on the science
there is only a 90-second chemical
release in your body it's called the
90-second rule when your body starts to
stomach starts to flutter when your
heart starts to race when you feel this
feeling of fear that you have that's
unique to you
based on the science there's a 90-second
rule and all of the chemical release
that's happening because your body is
going into a state of being alert it
only
sticks around for 90 seconds
as long as you don't let your thoughts
race if your thoughts start to race
you'll start to agitate the situation
the next time that your body goes into a
state of alert stomach gets tight you
feel frozen you get stuck you feel your
neck when the body starts to do that
number one
just remember it means your body is
getting ready to be alert and pay
attention doesn't and it does not mean
you're going to lose control it does not
mean you're in danger it does not mean
to stop or to shut up
i want you to take a deep breath
count to five five four three two one
that's it and realize that the hormones
that just got released because you're
about to do something
they only last 90 seconds that's it
you can breathe slowly you can count to
90 you can get up and walk around you
can do 90 seconds of jumping jacks you
can meditate for 90 seconds you can
ground your feet in your chair
and wiggle a minute so that you feel
your body in your chair
and take deep breaths
and what you're going to find is that
you're going to be blown away you're
going to be blown away because what
you're going to see is that in
90 seconds flat
you can go from being somebody who has
an upset stomach
and who would normally not go talk to
your boss who would normally not walk
into that gym who would normally
not make that call
in 90 seconds flat you can manipulate
your body state to calm down and you
will notice that your thoughts do not
race your thoughts calm down you're in
full control and now you can speak up
and now you can show up the truth is if
you want control in your life if you
want to make things happen you have to
be able to expect that you're going to
get a no
and do it anyway so what do i mean when
i say if you want control expect an o
well there's a couple things that i mean
by it number one if you're somebody that
gets paralyzed because you want things
to be perfect
perfectionism is a way that most of us
try to
handle or mitigate or
make sure that we don't hear no we
assume that if we're perfect
everything's going to go okay and so we
spend all of our energy thinking about
our dating profile or thinking about the
business plan or thinking about how to
make things perfect
and the reason why we do that is we're
terrified to hear no we're terrified to
put something out there that's not
perfect because if it's not perfect you
might get a no um one of the better ways
to handle this is to actually expect a
no you know i saw the most incredible
quote by our friend faustina
over in australia she's a very famous dj
and friend of ours from australia and
she put out the most amazing quote and
i'm going to get it totally wrong
but it's something like this
you have to be yourself
because
how else are the people who are looking
for you gonna find you
and i think particularly when it comes
to dating
what we tend to do is we are so afraid
of being rejected by anybody out there
that we try to be somebody that we're
not
that we put out a fake
improved or what we think is improved
version of ourselves in order to not
hear no and most of us pretend to be
somebody that we're not when we fear
rejection when we believe that how we
are who we are isn't good enough and so
that's why it's so important for you to
understand that you have to be willing
to hear a no you have to be willing to
hear a no from the wrong people so that
the people that are looking for you can
find you so that the people who want to
be part of your business can be part of
your business if you're putting a fake
person out there or a pretend perfect
person out there because you think
that's gonna that's gonna save you from
rejection
you're actually screwing yourself over
here's your new definition of passion
passion is simply
energy
that's all that it is okay
passion
is what you feel
when you are energized and excited
about what you're doing okay i want you
to think about that for a minute i want
you to think about a moment in time
when you felt incredibly passionate
about something okay and why don't you
in the comments tell me where are you
watching from and tell me about a moment
in time when you felt incredibly
passionate about what you were doing
about where you were
about the people that you are with
describe that moment for me because when
you start to
really investigate
passion as energy
this is what you're going to discover
those moments when you are super
passionate like i'm sure my kids would
write down when they're doing community
theater with all their friends
i would write down whenever i'm doing
any kind of creative project with my
team
i'm incredibly energized whenever i'm
doing group
exercise stuff climbing a mountain uh
doing a 5k race doing some sort of
walk-a-thon i'm incredibly energized by
that whenever i'm um doing some sort of
creative project incredibly energized by
that whenever i'm working with our video
team incredibly energized by that
whenever i am
coaching someone or giving advice i am
incredibly energized by that and so what
i want you to understand is that if you
look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt
passion
i'm being very deliberate now i'm
talking this morning on coffee talk
because passion is a huge topic for so
many of you and you've been so focused
on trying to figure out what job is
going to make me uh passionate what job
is my passion what is my purpose on the
earth i'm going to tell you what your
purpose on earth is right now your
purpose on earth is to figure out how to
align your life so that you feel more
energized and excited by it that's it
and it begins with you
following the energy and following your
natural enthusiasm you're not going to
think your way to passion you can't
think your way to finding something that
you feel in your heart it doesn't work
that way you got to feel your way into
it it's inside of you do you understand
there's no passion out there somewhere
the passion is in here and so what you
have to do first is you've got to stop
thinking that you're going to find it
somewhere and you've got to realize that
passion is about unlocking something
that's already in you for years when i
felt stressed out
when i felt overwhelmed when i started
to feel
burnt out
i would literally react to the feeling
of being stressed and overwhelmed
by stepping on the accelerator
i used to believe that i just if i just
ran faster
if i just moved quickly
i would be able to outrun the overwhelm
that i was feeling
and what i have found time and time and
time again
is that you cannot gain control by
speeding up
the way that you gain control of
anything in life is by slowing down and
whenever i feel like my own life is like
that car where the wheel's shaking and
i'm going and i feel like i'm going to
lose control and my instinct is to step
on the gas and go go go
i have taught myself in those moments to
stop
get off social media
cancel meetings
take a couple personal days
put your phone away
get out in nature if you can
take a deep breath
start your morning slowly because it's
in those moments where you slow
everything down that you
really
gain control again because you start to
get located in your body bottom line if
you feel overwhelmed do what i did
do not step on the accelerator
take the off ramp
slow down
take a day off
you will learn when you take your foot
off the gas
and you allow yourself to coast to a
stop
that
the world will go on
you need a break
and when you stop racing around and
running and dealing with the stress and
you will literally
see in the calm what the path forward is
okay so i wanted to make this video
because i know in some area of your life
you are wanting to start something
you're wanting to put yourself out there
more and you are holding yourself back
and one place that i see this playing
out all the time is the fact that so
many people probably you
are self-conscious and nervous about
putting videos online you're
self-conscious and nervous about talking
about your business or sharing the
breakthroughs that you're having or just
showing up in a bigger bolder more
self-express way because heck it makes
your life more fun when you do and so
you have this deep yearning to be doing
more and then i know exactly what
happens to you you look at the number of
people that follow you
you then say who the hell am i to say
that you then go nobody's going to watch
it anyway and i want to share with you
brand new research that blows that lame
excuse although normal excuse right out
of the water it was published literally
this month from ohio state university
and it proves that when it comes to
video content
the video content that people find
compelling
has nothing to do with the number of
views that it has
it has to do
with the person and the message that's
being communicated to be compelling to
make an impact to be influential because
i know everybody wants to raise their
influence and their visibility and to
show up in bigger ways it is all about
the message
and you're in control of that
do you communicate with passion do you
have conviction about what you're
talking about you could be talking about
oh i don't know
uh whether you like white cords or these
like black cords with this end or
whether you like this kind of end or
this end or where you like this cap or
whether you oh i love to drink this way
because i have a big nose and then this
way
[Music]
and i'm telling you you don't have to
have this thing on you could literally
talk about anything and if you bring
passion and you bring conviction to what
you're talking about
people will pay attention
that's what real influence is it's the
ability to show up in ways and have
conviction and passion about the things
that you believe in whether you're
talking about a water bottle cap or
you're talking about how to be healthier
happier or more effective in your life
so enough with the excuses enough with
worrying about how many followers you
have or whether or not aunt sue is gonna
like the video or not or what people are
gonna think
the only thing that matters is the
conviction and passion
that you communicate with and of course
getting started so based on the research
get started put that video out you got
to be honest with yourself
if there are things about your
appearance that are within your control
whether it is the shape that you're in
whether it's the health choices that
you're making whether it's how you take
care of yourself in terms of self-love
and you're not
taking action in those areas
the lack of action says to your brain
you don't care about yourself and so
what i want you to do is pick one thing
one behavior that you could do every day
the high fives one of them pick another
one and i want you to practice doing it
and it's a behavior if you think about
the person that you want to become
what's that person do every day that you
don't do right now
and when you start to do the thing that
the person you want to become is doing
you leverage something called behavioral
activation therapy
and that is a whole body of research
that says when you act like the person
you want to become it's the most
powerful way to change a habit
it's even a better therapy than
talk therapy because the action proves
to your brain that you're becoming that
person you're seeing the change through
the action and so then the brain catches
up and starts to relate to you like a
person that's confident or a person who
adores their appearance or a person that
celebrates themselves exactly as they
are you know when we moved to vermont i
got a brand new uh primary care doctor
and i thought he said something really
interesting he's this great guy um he
settled here because his wife's family
uh is from vermont and so he's now lived
here for 40 years and at the end of my
uh
first appointment with him
he said a really interesting thing to me
he kind of chuckled because of course
i'm very entertaining and bubbly and all
this stuff and he said it's going to be
really fun to watch what happens to you
and i'm like
what doctor says that to somebody
and i said what do you mean and he said
well i'll tell you mel
in the
years that i've been practicing as a
primary care doctor in southern vermont
i have seen
so many people move to vermont
they're seeking a choir lifestyle
they're seeking
a change a new chapter
and what i find is
if you're what you're actually seeking
is a safe haven
and you're running away from your
problems
a funny thing happens
your problems always go with you and
when you move somewhere very quiet
the solitude just magnifies that that
you were trying to get away from
and so if you're starting a new chapter
because you're excited
and you're reinventing yourself that's
fabulous still take time to complete the
last chapter that you were in so you
step into the new chapter with all of
the wisdom and the gratitude and the
learning and the growth that you gained
if you are starting a new chapter as so
many of us do because we are running
away from the old us we're running away
from a bad relationship we're closing
the door on something that wasn't
working
you better make sure you take the time
to
think through and journal about this
last chapter
who you've been the habits you no longer
want to repeat the mistakes that you
made what you've learned what you're
running from and more importantly what
changes you're going to make and how
this new chapter is going to support you
in doing it and in becoming the person
that you're meant to be
without that intentional moment of
reflection and without that intentional
moment where you're going to list out
the behaviors and thinking patterns and
habits you're changing
my doctor's right
you're just going to take all that crap
you're running from right into this new
chapter i think i am um
engaged in emotional eating right now
uh it is 2
22 in the afternoon
and the wheels are off today and i know
why the reason why is because i did not
stick to my normal routine
and i've noticed since i did not stick
to my routine my day has sort of slid
off the rails in terms of the decisions
that i'm making
um
it's really random like i
had
my son's chicken nuggets for lunch and
there's half an apple that i ate i have
not finished the amount of water i
normally drink it's 2 23 and
i made myself an ice cream sundae
because you know why the hell not
and so as i'm sitting here
enjoying my ice cream sundae i just
thought to myself god
am i emotionally eating right now
oh my god this is so good
if i really unpack what i'm feeling
right now
it's raining it's freezing i am
mentally in a creative block and i'm
gonna get this tool that we use on the
mel robin show out i call it the word
wheel so i'm gonna show you the word
wheel right now
here's how you use a word wheel the
average person can only name three
emotions happy sad and angry
but our emotions are actually much
deeper and more complex and the secret
to getting unstuck or untriggered or
freed up in any situation is to find the
words that describe what you are truly
feeling so i'm going to start with the
core emotion of anger and fear and work
out from there
and so as i look at the word wheel
i feel inadequate as a writer
i feel worried
that i'm not gonna have a creative
breakthrough
i feel helpless the big one is
i feel inadequate as a writer
whoa big breakthrough
i am
feeding
my inadequacy with an ice cream sundae
you know what's interesting
is simply finding the word that i feel
inadequate as a writer and that makes me
feel afraid that the book isn't going to
be good that it's not going to be as
good as i want it's not going to do as
well it's not going to get any um
accolades or good reviews it's not going
to make a difference in your life
as you identify the feeling and for me
it's inadequate that sunday doesn't
taste very good anymore
because it wasn't a sunday
that i was craving
it was reassurance and comfort from this
deeper feeling that i was feeling
wow that's powerful stuff
really powerful stuff
so if you
are at a moment where you catch yourself
emotionally eating
or you just feel untethered or numb pull
out the word wheel you can find it at
mel robbins.com
and um i think you'll find it to be a
really incredible tool
that will
help you locate what you're truly
working through and instead of reaching
for
an ice cream sundae which honestly is
going to now tank my mood because of all
the sugar
and make me feel
lethargic if you can identify the word
which for me is inadequate
inferior worried
um frustrated
you can let those feelings rise up move
through them
and then move on
two hours later and let me tell you the
impact of having fed my feelings first
of all i am totally
bloated
so uh i realized that that's not big but
you know for me
my stomach is just like oh
because all that sugar and
dairy that i just pounded down is now
sitting here like a rock
and this is the problem with emotional
eating is you get caught in this cycle
where you feed these feelings and then
your body starts to tank and your mood
tanks and your stomach gets bloated and
so then you start to make yourself wrong
and feel ashamed and feel like a bad
person because you did it
so how do you stop emotional eating
and what business do i have giving any
of us advice given that i just did it
well i'm going to tell you what i'm
going to do tomorrow when i inevitably
hit that creative block
is emotional eating you know that it's
emotional if it's
comes on suddenly if you
aren't just craving something but you
are
reaching for something that is a treat
or that's soothing
and before i do that tomorrow would my
writer's block inevitably happens again
i will take a deep breath and i will ask
myself what am i feeling
why
am i reaching for this food am i hungry
or am i trying to soothe or comfort or
distract myself
because i was clearly trying to soothe
and distract myself from the feelings
that writer's block
was bringing up
and now
i need to get some gas sex or something
because i gotta distract myself from the
gas pains that i have for my emotional
eating
but you know honestly the discomfort i'm
feeling right now that's not going to
stop me from doing it tomorrow the only
thing that will stop this pattern is
spotting the pattern and using the tools
that i just gave you identify what
you're feeling ask you why it is you're
reaching for this if you're not hungry
but you're trying to soothe distract or
reward yourself you're feeding some
feeling
recognize the feeling put down the ice
cream go for a walk choose something
healthy address the feeling
don't reach for the food okay so there
are 7.5 billion people on this
incredible planet verse but do you know
how many of them you're responsible for
truly
one you see while you're busy taking
care of everybody else who is it that's
taking care of you you were given one
human being one mind one soul one body
one life we are so bananas focused about
what people who know nothing
about what's going on in your life think
and what happens is you can get so
concerned about the opinions and the
judgments of all these other people that
you're taking care of and that you're
being nice to that you forget about the
one person's opinion that actually
matters and that's yours and when
silencing yourself and being way more
concerned about what everybody thinks
becomes a pattern you are holding
yourself back you don't go after your
dreams because you're way too caught up
in what everybody else is thinking for
every person that's got a side eye or an
eye roll or an opinion about what you're
doing i promise you when you make the
decision to live your life for you
the right people will find you is this
gonna be easy to chart your own path to
hear what people have to say but not let
it define what you do next
it's gonna take a little bit of practice
but once you make the decision to live
your life for you i promise you
everything will fall into place
my sparkly sneakers this is a great
story about a bunch of topics it's a
story about confidence it's a story
about being comfortable in your own skin
it's a story about being yourself no
matter where you are or what you're
doing
and it's a story about the power
of your unique self-expression and your
unique self-expression comes out and is
amplified when you feel comfortable in
your own skin i got into the speaking
business gosh six or seven years ago i
had a tedx talk that went crazy viral
that's what started the speaking
business and when i first got into the
speaking business
i was really intimidated because i was
new to it and i wanted to do a very good
job and i wanted to fit in so i looked
around at what all the top people in the
industry of motivational speaking and
speaking on the corporate circuit were
doing and i noticed that all the women
uh were dressed in heels wearing pencil
skirts or beautiful dresses the kind of
thing that you might see a news anchor
wearing like a nice dress heels so i
just wore what everybody else was
wearing didn't even occur to me to wear
something else because here i am trying
to break into a new industry so i look
at everybody at the top i copy what
they're doing and i am not
comfortable in high heels yes if my
husband chris and i are going out on
date night i can rock them like the best
of them but walking through a convention
center in them
standing on a stage for an hour and a
pair of heels while you're trying to
hold in your stomach because you're
being broadcast on a big screen and
you're wearing a dress like it was
the
least comfortable outfit i could
possibly wear very self-conscious in it
i'm not that graceful in a pair of heels
so i sort of like
on a stage
but that's what i did for the first
couple years
so i was in miami this must have been
probably five years ago i was in miami
and i just gotten off stage take off the
heels take off the dress put on a pair
of jeans and a t-shirt i got like an
hour to kill before i have to leave for
the airport i'm gonna fly to vegas
because i've got a speech in vegas the
next morning so i'm walking uh down
collins ave in south beach in miami
and
i walk past this store unfortunately
it's not there anymore i loved this
store
and there in the window
were the most amazing high-top sneakers
i had ever seen in my entire life i was
like a moth to the flame
let me show you these bad boys because
these are the originals
this right here
notice the gold shimmery sparkle
and the
confident blaze orange i didn't own
anything like this i'd never seen
anything like this i immediately thought
whoa
this
i bet is what like a justin bieber kind
of wears i mean these are insanely cool
i went inside
and they were
pretty expensive i'd never spent that
kind of my i wasn't a sneaker head yet
but i thought hey i i i spend that kind
of money on a pair of nice heels so why
not treat myself to a pair of sneakers
okay
so i get back to the hotel i pack up i
hop the flight i get to vegas now i wake
up the next morning and i have a tech
check which is where you rehearse the
speech and go through like all the
technology rehearsals before the event's
starting my tech check is at 7 30. the
doors to the event open at 8 and i'm on
stage at 8 30. and i had a red dress my
heels or so i thought
so i crack open that's what i was
planning on wearing i crack open the
suitcase there are no heels
i have left the heels
in the hotel room back in miami all i
have are the birkenstocks that i wore on
the plane and i wore out in vegas last
night
and my new justin bieber high top
sneakers and i have exactly 15 minutes
to get to the tech rehearsal and nothing
else is open so birkenstocks justin
bieber i think we'll go with the justin
bieber sparkly high tops i slapped those
puppies on i walked from my hotel room
all the way through the casino floor
past all the restaurants and the shops
to the convention center which you know
is like a two mile walk i was so happy
to be not only in my red dress but more
importantly in my justin bieber sneakers
because it was super comfortable to walk
there that way i get to the backstage
area and for the first time in two years
something happened
and let me tell you what happened
one of the guys that was on the
production crew
turned
and goes
ah
cool sneakers that was like the first
time
somebody in production had
really acknowledged me for something
other than the job in two years so i was
like huh and as i started walking toward
the backstage area everybody i passed
cool kicks oh those are cool well those
are cool and i'm like
this is wild nobody's ever complimented
on my like this is people are
and so i did the tech rehearsal and then
this was the moment of truth when i
walked out onto that stage it was at the
mgm arena
and uh there were like 5 000 real estate
agents in the audience i was there to
deliver a speech for re max
it was the first time i'd ever walked on
a stage
where i actually felt like myself
it was also the first time
that i felt the audience
kind of lean forward
and go oh
she seems kind of cool but when you walk
onto a stage and heals in a dress you're
like the authority and you're on a stage
and you're talking at people
there's something about walking onto a
stage or walking through life and having
something fun that you're wearing that
makes you relatable and interesting and
real
and from that moment forward i have
never
not worn sparkly speakers for work i
wore them every day on my daytime talk
show
i'm embarrassed to tell you that i
probably have 20 pairs of these i love
this is my favorite these are my
favorite well i like these are my
favorite because these are the originals
but i would say these are my second
favorite because i like the low top and
i love the blue
i love these um which have a big silver
kind of thing these are super
comfortable and i've got a bunch of
these and these did not even come with
sparkles so i literally bought swivarsky
crystals or whatever the hell they're
called and got a glue gun out and put
them on myself
if you're looking for sparkly sneakers
there's all kinds of them out there
these days it's the coolest thing in the
world but dazzled me sneakers are a
thing
whether you go to dsw or nordstroms or
zappos or anywhere you can find them and
so the moral of the story the secret to
confidence is being comfortable in your
own skin one thing that's true about
life is that things are always changing
around you always
whether you are moving into a new season
or in in
school
and all of a sudden your kid's school
schedules change or you're moving into a
new season of work and all of a sudden
your work life is changing or you're
moving into a new season of your
marriage or of your health or of
anything life changes all the time which
is why it's really important to be
self-aware and to make the small changes
that help you
enjoy
and seize all the opportunities from the
season of life work family relationships
that you're in right now the only thing
that you can do is change yourself for
the better and hope
that
that means that when you change for the
better
that your
friends and the people that you love and
care about are inspired
and encourage change for the better too
and if you have people in your life that
are stuck they probably are all
resigned
they don't believe that their behavior
can change this they don't believe that
their attitude can change this maybe
they're feeling a little beaten down in
order to make it stick go brick by brick
one of the things that's interesting
about having big dreams and big goals is
that oftentimes
the fact that the goals and the dreams
that we have are so big
it makes them uh
really really difficult to achieve
because you spend so much time thinking
about how big
the idea or the dream is that you become
paralyzed in the moment around taking
action how do you build a house
by laying
a foundation
brick by brick by brick you go one small
brick at a time and it's exactly the
same thing for your goals by the way so
if you think about where you're at in
this moment and you think about the path
that will take you forward to your big
dreams or to this change that you want
to make and i'm going to use the eating
program as my example because this is
daunting to me
i can come up with a million reasons
right now just like i'm sure you can
come up with a million reasons why you
can't run a marathon you can't do the
singing telegram business you can't take
nature pictures for a living you can't
be more connected to your husband which
is what leanne wants you can't launch
that aromatherapy business i can't
possibly do a structured eating program
with the scale right now because i
travel too much because i'm too busy
because i'm lazy because i'm not
deliberate like my bracelet remember my
my intent bracelet i'm reminding myself
to be deliberate which is probably why
i'm thinking about this program
the path between where i'm at and where
you want to get to is the same it is a
brick path
and it is comprised of a ton of little
bricks that come together to take me
forward and so when you think about a
goal or you think about a dream as a
million little bricks that come together
and lay a path forward
that's the way visually you can break
down your goals and so for me you know
what that one brick could be today it
could be asking chris or my uh
brother-in-law for the phone number
of the person not even making the call
people i'm talking about breaking it
down to one brick so i will get that
phone number and i will write it down in
my little red book or i will write it
down in my five second journal and that
way i will have the number and guess
what the brick is going to be tomorrow
the brick tomorrow is going to be to
call the guy
right and make an appointment and then
the next brick might be to read a little
bit and so the key is going brick by
brick to make it stick because if you
think you can lay the whole path between
where you're at and where you want to go
right now you're nuts why do you think
that is in human beings that you know
things are going bad we won't change
if they're going good we won't change
but it's almost like we need a massive
breakdown near death experience divorce
covid for us to see clearly to start
changing
well there's a really simple answer
patterns
so the thing about all human beings is
that we are pattern
learning machines
and if you feel
stuck or broken i guarantee you while
you feel that way you're not you have a
pattern of behavior or a pattern of
thinking that is broken
and we
need
to be disrupted
because we love our patterns
and even people that i know like i've
heard
even when we're in pain we're like
pain's familiar for a lot of people yeah
so a lot of people like you may be
listening to lewis and i talking and you
grew up in a super chaotic household
maybe your parents argued all the time
maybe your dad or mom were in and out
maybe there was a lot of fighting maybe
there was actual abuse i don't know what
was going on but it was chaotic as hell
and so as an adult
you have vowed yourself you are not
going to repeat that pattern
but what ends up happening is because as
a little kid you observed witness
absorbed the pattern of chaos in your
nervous system
unless you go about the intentional work
of breaking the pattern of chaos
you will create it in your own life
because it's what's familiar
you won't understand why do i keep
dating these why do i why do i go to
these bosses that treat me like crap
because you don't know
what it feels like
to be in a relationship with either a
boss or a romantic partner or a roommate
that is consistent because for the first
18 years of your life you lived in a
state called when's the next shoe gonna
drop right
and so wherever it is in your life that
something is broken there is a pattern
that you don't see yet that is making
you continue to stay in a broken
situation
it's all that thinking that overthinking
that thinking too big thinking big is
about dreams thinking big is about goals
thinking big is about your heart and
your soul and figuring out what you want
then once you do that and you think big
and you see where you're headed boom you
got to come back and you've got to go
brick by brick to make that vision stick
you've got to go brick by brick to make
the action stick you've got to go brick
by brick to lay that pathway forward and
to keep going and let me tell you
something i don't care how busy you are
i don't care how tired you are i don't
care how much there is to do to make
this big dream forward you have time to
lay one brick a day you really do
you really do and this is the secret
everybody this is the secret to
everything it's to understanding that
there is no timeline to getting your
dreams done
all there is to do is to allow your
heart and soul to dream big
to see the path forward and then to pull
yourself into the moment every day and
have the discipline to be deliberate to
lay one brick on that path that's it and
to keep reminding yourself that
everything that you're learning on the
way is you lie bricks down and you move
forward a little at a time
is helping you build the path and there
will be times that you start to lay
bricks in this direction and you realize
whoa wait a minute i'm going over here
and my dream is over there i guess i
better lay bricks over here and head
back in the direction then you're going
to go this way that's great because
everything that you learned over here
is going to be exactly what you needed
in order to be
doing what your big dream is having a
breakdown is one of the biggest things
on the planet because what you get is
you get a break from your own
and you can look
objectively at where you are and for the
first time
look ahead and say well what do i want
to go create and nine times out of ten
if you're discouraged right now if
you've got financial devastation if
you've if you're facing something that
is making this moment in time as hard
for you as life was for lewis and i in
2008 during the last recession
i beg you
ask yourself honestly if what you had is
actually what you wanted
the thing that you just lost that that
job that you brushed about all the time
a relationship that was bad to you yeah
yes or the friends you can't hang out
with because it's convenient and you
can't you're in court like actually ask
yourself if this is what you wanted or
were you just used to it
being used to something
louis i think is the biggest reason why
people don't change
i asked my mother i love my mother i
love my parents i've been married 51
years
which is a feat because they were my mom
was a teen mom but
uh i asked her once if she'd go to a
personal development seminar with me
what'd you say
are you [ __ ] kidding me
why would i want to change at my age wow
i might discover i hate my life
wow
i was like okay i'm just gonna leave
that right there
right
i started thinking about luck because
there are
for a long time in my life i started to
think that luck was for other people
that luck was just one of those things
that if you were lucky enough to be born
with luck you won the lottery you got
the job you wanted your family got along
and the truth is there's a tremendous
amount of science behind luck that luck
is something that you can make for
yourself that you can become luckier
based on the things that you do and the
things that you think about and one of
the things about lucky people is a lot
of lucky people make their luck because
they have trained themselves to think
optimistically and one small trick that
you can use in your life that is free
you can do it today is when you go to
bed tonight before you go to sleep i
want you to write down
one thing
that happened today that was good that's
it
every night before you go to bed i want
you to write down one thing that
happened today that's good in fact let's
do it right now in the comments
go to the comments and tell me one thing
that has happened today that you can
think of that's good just one thing
maybe you got up on time maybe you
didn't have traffic today uh on the way
to work maybe uh you haven't fought with
your kids this morning maybe you got to
the gym maybe you woke up and for the
first hour of the day you didn't make
yourself wrong all of those things while
they're really little
don't dismiss them because those are
things that are good and the reason why
i want you to start a practice where
every night before you go to bed or if
you don't want to do it at night do it
in the morning every night before you go
to bed write down one thing that
happened today that was good the reason
why you're doing this is you are
training yourself to start to spot the
good believe it or not training yourself
to start to look for the good in your
life fundamentally trains your mind away
from looking at the negative so that you
start seeing this thing that's positive
about your life versus that thing that's
negative about your life the secret to
life and this is so
hard to grasp
is to just be yourself that's the secret
there's only one you
there's only ever going to be one you
there's never going to be another you
and the way you make your mark in this
world the way that you learn how to
believe in yourself
the way that you discover the people
that you're supposed to surround
yourself with the job that you or career
path that you're supposed to have
is by being the real you my mind can be
my worst enemy i was laying in bed last
night and i'd fallen asleep and i kept
waking up and you know what i was
thinking about i was waking up because i
could hear people in the hallway kind of
coming in from a late night of parting
and you know what the first thing that
my mind defaulted to
there being a fire in the hotel and i
started having these visions of my
daughter and i
going down the stairwell and getting
trapped and then i had visions of us
being on the balcony
on this room and fire kind of engulfing
and what are we doing are we tying a
rope wish i mean it's just insanity
absolute insanity and i
i use the techniques that i teach you i
went five four three two one i am not
thinking about this and the thought
disappeared because i
constantly reset my mindset and you know
one of the reasons why i'm telling you
this is if you are tired of feeling
negative if you feel often that your own
thoughts are the things that trip you up
in life that you wish that your mind
were more positive i'm telling you that
i'm the same way
just because i teach this stuff just
because i study this just because i do
what i do for a living doesn't make me
immune to what it means to be human and
what it means to be human is that your
brain and your body want you to survive
your brain and your body remember
situations that scare the daylights out
of you your brain and your body try to
talk you out of anything that makes you
feel risky and your brain
given that it has been um trained by
situations in the past and given that
you allow it to worry all the time you
have a habit of doing it if you're not
careful and you're not deliberate your
brain will default to scary crap like
mine was last night that doesn't mean
you're broken it means that your brain
is thinking something that's broken and
it's time for you to reset your mindset
and pull it back do you know what the
one
strategy
one strategy that is associated with
making more money
for women do you know if there's what is
one strategy
that will help you make more money as a
woman when you work in a company
you can put it in the comments you can
guess
uh no it's not working longer hours
no it's not taking the notes in the
meeting
no it's not um doing everybody else's
work for them
the one strategy based on research that
will actually translate to you making
more money
is making sure your achievements are
known
and i want to dig deeper into this
because
there are two kinds of work right two
kinds of work i want you to shift your
paradigm and the way that you think
about work because you do two kinds of
work you do work that is visible and
that is the work that you get credit for
so visible work consists of the ideas
that you share in a meeting it consists
of the things that you talk to your boss
about it consists of the work that
you're doing that people see
it consists of the results that you
generate that are reported and discussed
and most importantly it consists of the
projects that you are working on that
are strategically aligned with the goals
of the company that people know about
invisible work on the other hand is all
the stuff you don't get credit for so
all those folks that you mentor in
private you're not getting credit for
that you should still do it but i'm
going to tell you how to do it
differently um answering the same
question over and over and over again
for multiple people on telephone calls
that's invisible if you only make one
change this year in your career i want
you to take on a habit of making sure
your accomplishments
are known that the things that you're
doing are more visible the most
important thing hang out with people
that cheer for you
this is so important i don't like i
can't say this enough
behavior is contagious they have proven
this they have proven this google the
framingham study it was a really famous
heart study that was done where they
looked at human behavior over what's
called a longitudinal study which
basically means i studied people for a
number of years
and they found that you catch the
behavior of other people if you hang out
with smokers over time your objection to
smoking lowers because you're hanging
out with smokers and you become
socialized to it and you are more likely
to smoke if you hang out with happier
people if you hang out with people that
are more successful than you if you hang
out with people that run all the time
guess what happens
you become socialized to those positive
behaviors the fastest way to make a
behavior change is to hang out with
people that are positive that are
cheering for you that are up to cool
stuff that are so busy and engaged in
their life they don't have time for
passive aggressive [ __ ] because
they're busy building something and
being appreciative and that's who you
should hang out with what do you do when
you feel overwhelmed because your home
life your work life your side hustle
trying to take care of yourself
you can't find the time what i always do
is i always come back to the basics
when you tip into overwhelm go back to
the basics
start with a morning routine
i know
the second that i
am in overwhelmed which i am right now
uh i have lost the discipline
of having a consistent morning routine i
still wake up without my phone
i still don't look at my phone but i
haven't taken those 30 minutes every
morning for myself to plan my day
so i have been waking up i don't look at
my phone but i go straight for the
coffee
i think about what i need to do and
since every single day this week it's
been a speech or a massive meeting
that's taken precedence but i have not
put in the discipline that i talk about
all the time
of just taking 30 minutes to plan
what's important to me you know when you
start to say
i have to finish the newsletter
i have to work on my book
ah
i have to do that thing that i need to
do
ah
i have to pick oh i have to pick up my
kids oh i gotta i have to talk to
switch have to with get to
it's a little word reversal that changes
everything i get to work on the
newsletter this morning
and i get to write something that almost
400 000 people are gonna read i get to
work on a book manuscript today as we
fly to orlando
i get to pick up my kids tomorrow when i
land i get to start to say i get to
because that switch of going i have
[Music]
which adds weight and burden
switching it to i get to makes it a
privilege
it makes you be grateful about what you
get to do because honestly it is a
privilege whatever it is that you're
doing and when you come from that place
and you
think this i get to not that i have to
um you will bring power to what you get
to do when people are passive aggressive
or they give you fake compliments or
they give you the silent treatment
typically that's fueled out of jealousy
and jealousy is nothing more than an
emotion that people feel when
you have something that they feel they
deserve
and a lot of us feel jealousy
because it's easier to be jealous of
somebody
and to
stay in a negative state than it is to
push yourself
to do the work to get the thing that you
want and so it's almost like it's your
unrealized dream showing up in your face
and what's also right in your face is
the fact that somebody else worked for
it and
you haven't yet and so instead of going
oh note to self time to start cheering
for myself and use that example as
something positive to motivate myself a
lot of people tend to be like i hate you
i hate you because you have what i have
so here's what you're going to do when
you deal with people that are passive
aggressive or jealous first of all
um
don't
don't
get triggered by it
that's their stuff it's not your stuff
second
um you're doing the right thing if
people ask share what worked for you
third
distance yourself you don't need to hang
out with these people if you're making
positive changes in your life hang out
with the people that are cheering for
you
just because you've known people for
years doesn't mean you have to hang out
with them for the years to come
so distance yourself and fourth
if it's really passive aggressive
um
say something for those of you that feel
very overwhelmed because of home work
side hustle
and you're a woman
you probably also feel guilty about
taking time to work on your side hustle
that's because women girls we are raised
to be good girls we're raised to be good
daughters were raised to uh be seen and
not heard were raised to take care of
people it's socialized into you and you
see your mothers by the way also
sacrifice everything to take care of
everybody else and to put themselves
laps this is a learned behavior so if
you also are a woman you probably feel
guilty for taking time for yourself
stop that you have to stop that
the reason why you have to stop that is
first of all if you're a mom you've got
to show your daughters and your sons
what it looks like to pursue your dreams
secondly uh as a woman you're not going
to get what you want if you're
constantly putting guilt on yourself for
taking time for yourself and third the
only way you will discover the power and
potential inside of you is if you push
that generational [ __ ] to the side
and you actually realize that your life
is for you that your mom you know why
she sacrificed everything she did
because she wanted you
to pursue your dreams so knock it off
with the guilt because the guilt is also
contributing to the overwhelm the guilt
is making you not talk to your partner
or your boss or your colleagues or your
friends about what you need for support
the guilt is adding weight to
you not being able to carve out the time
and be disciplined to find the time for
yourself and so it has got to go you
hear me get rid of it isn't it
interesting that age is something that
measures the amount of time that's gone
by but
don't you have a lot of baggage about
your age you're either too young or
you're too old or too much time has
passed or you blew it and you wasted
your 30s or now that you're 40 or this
or you're only 20. i mean it's insane
how much baggage we all have about our
age and so i'm writing about
how to
remove that story
and how to recognize that whatever time
has passed is passed whether it's a
teeny amount of time because you're just
a high school student or it's a lot of
amount of time because you're 60 years
old and to understand that life is an
inside game
and it's all about your mindset and it's
all about what you do
with the time that you have right now
you can launch anything you can begin
anything period as long as you are
willing to do the work for it
if you're somebody that suffers from
anxiety first of all here's what you
need to know it's not a disease
period
it's not a disease so here's what you
need to understand
anxiety always begins with a worry
always
it begins with a thought that is
triggered by something so if you suffer
from anxiety you wake up in the morning
and your mind spins you lay in bed at
night and your mind spins you walk into
work and you feel anxious in your body i
want you to write down all the things
that trigger you to feel anxious
interestingly another major trigger
is
being home
or going home
and that moment right before your
partner walks in the door
if you feel anxious when your partner's
about to walk in or you're about to walk
into your own home that is a major
signal that you are in the wrong
relationship that there is something
incredibly off and you either need to
get into counseling but that is one that
we hear a lot about wow
because you're walking into a situation
that feels uncertain yeah a lot of
people by the way had parents that were
abusive or parents that were yellers so
they also are experiencing ghosts from
the childhood of it's five o'clock dad's
about to come home and pour a drink and
everybody's on edge yeah
so write down the triggers okay
because having having kind of the
triggers ahead of time will help you
come up with a plan
for how you're going to catch yourself
when your mind defaults to the automatic
ways that it thinks
then what i want you to write down next
to the trigger is what exactly are you
worried about
so having the trigger and then the what
do i worry about i worry that my boss is
going to yell i worry that my partner's
going to yell i worry that i'm going to
get in trouble i worry that um you know
my friends are going to laugh at me i
worry that i'm going to be a whatever it
may be
then what you're going to do is you're
going to write down what i call an
anchor thought an anchor thought is
something that weighs you down and it
makes you excited
and so here's how the strategy works
with the five second rule
the next time you're in a situation and
let's just use the example of pulling
into your own driveway or your own
apartment and maybe you've got issues
with your boyfriend or girlfriend or
your roommate and that makes you
unsettled
you're
the second you pull in and you feel the
trigger
you're gonna go five four three two one
because i want to interrupt your mind
from going into
kind of like what if
and then you're going to drop in
the anchor thought
of the last time that you and your
roommate really got along well
or the last time that you stood up for
yourself and it went fine
yeah or a puppy or whatever you're gonna
say i'm so excited
to
deal with this yeah
and then you're going to get out of your
car even though your body is going to
feel a little unsettled and your mind's
going to race go five four three two one
if you start to like be like uh but
whatever
and then walk in the door
and what i'm teaching you to do is to
not let your mind hijack you
and it's very important because there's
a very tight nexus between
your habit of worrying and spiraling
your thoughts and the way your body
starts to amp up and so we want to
settle your mind so we don't agitate
your body you got it yeah and so if you
start to practice that over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again and for you 18 year olds that are
watching this use this with
the
nerves that you have about what you're
going to do with your life use this when
you catch yourself worrying about
college applications because worrying
about the applications won't get them
done
worrying about what your friends are
doing won't make it happen worrying
about what you're going to be doing when
you're 25 or how you're going to make
money it's not going to help you make
money right now it's only going to make
you miserable so 54321 cut off that
habit yeah
that'll stabilize your body and then go
to a vision of you at the age of 25
driving a car that you think is cool and
hanging out with a friend that's cool
and saying yourself i'm so excited
because i know i'm going to figure it
out
because you don't need to worry about
that right now yeah but it becomes a
habit that destroys your year this year
so the holidays are upon us and i wanted
to share my three rules around the
holidays to make sure that even if you
have a very dysfunctional family you can
focus on the fun in dysfunctional okay
so here are my three rules
and they're all like the three ps of the
holidays okay so you can think about
holiday dinner you don't like to eat
your peas these are the peas that you
want to focus on you ready number one no
politics
seriously
do not utter anything about anything
related to politics we live in a
crazy
whacked out time right now when it comes
to politics there is no safe topic even
if everybody voted for the same people
do not discuss it that's rule number one
no politics the second p leave the past
in the past
do not dance into thanksgiving dinner or
any holiday that you're celebrating
during this long season and expect it to
be the moment in time that you're going
to resolve everything that's happened to
you in your past
that belongs in a therapy session or
during a long walk in the woods when
you're actually focused on healing in
the past for now you just want to get
along with everybody you want to have a
fun time you don't want to make this too
heavy and you do not want to be the one
bringing the drama to the table
leave that to one of your uncles or your
aunts okay and number three pretend you
care okay no politics
don't heal the past pretend you care
it's not that difficult
you don't have to love everybody you
don't have to like everybody but show up
and actually demonstrate behavior that
makes people feel as if you care what
does that mean it means ask a lot of
questions
listen follow up with more questions and
you know the great thing about asking
lots of questions of the folks that are
there at the holidays with you number
one
it takes the focus off of you
so
if you're worried about talking about
where you are or you aren't in your life
ask a lot of questions you won't be
talking about yourself at all and number
two when other people are talking they
think you're very interesting that's
true the secret to human beings is be
interested because when you're
interested in everybody else suddenly
you're the most interesting person in
the room while they're talking when a
manager or a boss
defines norms
the team is 73 times more likely to work
hard to keep them and here's the kicker
they're
125 times more likely to address the
situation if there's somebody on the
team who is not operating within the
norms
you know i it's it's so obvious
i mean think about it if somebody were
to walk in
to work
and uh put their feet up on the desk and
turn on porn
and be sitting at their desk watching
porn would that be the norm
for your workplace i don't think so
unless you're working for playboy or
you're working in the porn industry
that would be so out of the norm that
everybody would address it immediately
period full stop
and what i want you to understand is
that when you take responsibility for
how you're acting on the team and you're
collaborative and you're supportive and
you're putting the team first and you're
modeling that behavior and when you also
bring the courage and you dare as brene
brown says to be brave enough to have
honest conversations with your
colleagues about what's acceptable and
what's not based on how things are
impacting you
you personally shift the culture in a
positive direction
now here's a trick about gratitude
writing down what you're grateful for
doesn't work unless you do it this way
because if you if i ask you what you're
grateful for everybody says the same
thing i'm grateful to be alive i'm
grateful for my health and i'm grateful
for my family and that's so generic
that you're not retraining your brain
right you've got to add in the because
i'm grateful for x because
and the added detail will make you
change up what you say and it will also
train your mind in a way that's more
detailed so it actually has a lasting
impact on the way that you view the
world just because you identify
and for me as a kid for whatever reason
i have my own version of feeling
invisible and feeling
like i'm not good enough and so my way
of coping both with my anxiety and being
a survivor of sexual abuse
and
um
and wanting love which we all need is i
was like an overachiever
and so i'm the kind of person that's
super busy and a go-getter because it
got me attention
and if i was the one that was super busy
and achieving i not only got praise but
it also insulates you
from
other people not picking you because
you're the one in a leadership role
doing the picking right and so there's a
part of me at the age of 51 that is
realizing
that you know this these feelings of
feeling unworthy
and
this hyper drive
to try to achieve
it's all coming
from a place of feeling inadequate or
like what i'm doing is not enough
and so at 50
having the talk show having a
best-selling book having the audible
originals having the platform everywhere
having the impact i still don't feel
being the most booked female speaker in
the world like you still don't feel so
stupid it's annoying and human beings
are annoying we are stuck with this
wiring like if you think about it like
all of the crap you believe is probably
a hangover from age 0 to 10.
that as adults we walk around thinking
the same stuff we thought as kids
and i
can't stand that i feel that way
but knowing it it allows me to catch it
before it has me
before it stops me from
having an event or writing that next
book or taking a risk one of the things
that i've learned in my business
is that
the mistakes are where all the learning
is and actually the mistakes and the
imperfect stuff that's where the gold is
everybody and so as you're sitting there
and you're thinking about doing stuff
and you're trying to make it perfect and
you're trying to come up with the right
script before you make that cold call or
you're trying to make sure your body
looks perfect before you put yourself
out there on match you are missing out
on your life
period and so i hope that if there's one
thing that i consistently inspire you to
do it's to start before you're ready
it's to put yourself out there and make
mistake it's to
have yourself go live and have it look
like crap and all of a sudden you
disconnect yourself and to be able to
laugh at yourself
to be able to shake it off like that is
a skill
it's a skill that that means that you're
self-aware it's a skill that means that
you're growing there's a lot of you
that are running from things
instead of running two things
and that's a huge difference running
from something
versus running to something and so i
want you to think about that for a
minute um
because you don't have to move across
country to change your life
and you don't have to do something
drastic to experience drastic positive
change
and here's the thing about running away
from your problems
running away from your past
have you ever noticed that when you run
away
it tends to follow you
you know i used to uh have this problem
in relationships
and the reason why i had this problem is
because i was a very unhappy person
i didn't like myself truly as a person
until probably four or five years ago i
spent as sad as this is i spent the
first 46 years of my life really not
liking myself really um feeling like i
wasn't a good person
really questioning the sanity of people
that were in love with me or that were
friends of mine because i had such a low
opinion of myself
and it didn't matter you know i i was
guilty not of moving from one city to
another
but i was guilty of moving from one
person to another
that i would literally
get in a relationship i would be in a
relationship for a year and then i would
start to feel that unsettled feeling
because what happens after a year of
being in a relationship well you got to
start working on it it's no longer the
thrill and the delight and it's new and
you're dating now it's just you and the
person in your life
there's nothing new about it and so all
your old crap starts to show up and
that's when you got to start to do the
work and so it was about the year or the
year and a half mark in almost every
single relationship that i would start
getting that itchy feeling and the
reason why i was getting that itchy
feeling is because my past was now there
this new relationship was no longer new
and so i was no longer distracted by it
and i was going to have to
deal with myself in order to be happy
and so what did i do for years not even
just years decades everybody i'm not i'm
not proud to admit this but i would
literally jump out of one relationship
and into another new one because another
new one would distract me from the fact
that i was an unhappy person
true story
and i think a lot of you who are unhappy
with yourselves are looking to move jobs
or looking to move
the city that you live in or you're
looking to change your relationship and
the problem isn't where you live the
problem isn't your job the problem isn't
the person that you're with the problem
is how you feel about yourself if you're
not facing a breakup personally in your
romantic life you still want to pay
attention because somebody that you care
about might be and this is advice that
you can give to them also breakups uh
happen in your career
you might be breaking up with a work
situation you might be breaking up with
a friend i know a lot of us are working
hard to draw boundaries and to surround
ourselves with more positive people and
we get questions every day about how you
do that and so breaking up with friends
can be just as traumatic as breaking up
with somebody that is a romantic partner
i have three steps to getting over a
breakup that i'm going to explain in a
minute but first i want to under i want
to explain some research to you to help
you put what you're feeling into context
because what you're going through when
you break up with somebody or you're
broken up with
is you literally
go through withdrawal
i'm not kidding and yeah i'm using the
word withdrawal
where else do you hear the word
withdrawal you hear the word withdrawal
when you hear about people withdrawing
from a drug and that's a lot uh similar
to what you're going through in fact
there was a study done by neuroscientist
lucy brown who found that like drug
abuse romantic love begins with that
euphoric feeling
it's a high right
and when the drug leaves your body or
the romance leaves your life what are
you left with you're left with the
withdrawal which is a craving for it
validate number one
breakfast breakups are painful but they
don't need to lead you broken so i want
you to validate where you're at it's
great that you're asking the question
you got to have a little bit of
compassion for yourself you got to
understand that you're going to be sad
for a while but please don't pour
gasoline on the sadness fire please
please please don't be staring at photos
of your ex please don't be uh putting
his or her social media face right in
front of your face it's gonna make it
worse but definitely validate the
sadness because you're going through a
major change and it might not be a
change that you wanted number two
separate this is the most important part
because the other thing that i don't
think any of us realize is that when you
get broken up with or you break up with
somebody
you don't realize how much of your daily
routine and the habits that you have and
the way that you go about your day was
tied to the person that you're no longer
with and so what you're not only dealing
with is not only missing the person but
your whole
life schedule
may have just been thrown off maybe you
two went to the same gym in the morning
maybe you got a text in the morning from
this person maybe you liked your little
facetime call at work maybe
your friend group became their friend
group and now all of a sudden that
you're broken up because you hung out
with their friends all the time you
don't have that social life anymore and
so it is so important for you to
recognize that you're not only facing
the person being gone but the habits
that marked your day and the other
people that maybe you hung out with and
the things that you did with your time
and the music that you listened to and
the food that you ate that those might
have all been dictated by the person you
were with and those are changing too so
it's important for you to separate your
self i think a lot of women in
particular when we get into a
relationship we tend to lose ourselves
we tend to morph into the person that
we're dating i used to do that all the
time and so
now we get to the third part
as you start to think about separating
right so you're validating where you're
at you're separating from this person we
need to get to the third part which is
celebrating you
now that you're broken up you have an
opportunity
you have an opportunity to rediscover
yourself because i guarantee you you
lost a bit of yourself in that
relationship and so as you think about
the way that the structure of your day
is changed what can you proactively
insert that is a celebration of the
things that you stopped doing
what have you been keeping yourself from
doing because you were in this
relationship that would celebrate you
who are the friends or family members or
colleagues that really lift you up and
how can you find more time to hang out
with them this is a time to celebrate a
moment when you get to rediscover you
the reason why your life isn't changing
is because your thinking isn't changing
if you wake up every morning and the
first thought in your head is making
yourself wrong
why can't i just get out of bed
why can't i just
go exercise why can't i eat healthy
the reason why
you can't change is because your
thinking is stopping you feel the fear
and do it anyway that famous quote i
want to tell you a little bit about the
science so there's this famous
neuroscientist called antonio damasio
and he did a really interesting study
where he discovered that our body senses
fear before our mind even realizes it
and when fear or danger
speaking to your boss calling a prospect
going to the gym when you're not proud
of the way that you look
um and you know it's not fear like
terror it's more that low-grade
agitation in your body i felt it
yesterday because i went to a boot camp
class yesterday and i'm not in good
shape and i don't do bootcat camp
classes and kendall and i are staying at
this hotel where holy cow everybody
seems like there's some sort of
professional weightlifter or instagram
model and so it was really intimidating
and i could feel
that agitation in my body that's the
kind of fear i'm talking about i'm not
talking about the
paralysis
fear your life is threatened and you
really are in a life or death situation
i'm talking about the low-grade
agitation
that is um there when you're about to do
something that makes you feel a little
uncomfortable so
when fear or danger is sensed in the
body your body begins a stress response
before your mind even catches up
and if you want to take control of your
life you got to take control of that
physical state and it starts with
catching these moments everyone
when you
um start to feel it i've looked into the
research there's only one
habit and skill just one
that has a direct impact on how much
money you make a direct impact on
whether or not you get the promotion and
the influence and the cash
money that you deserve and you know what
that is
any ideas
the one skill
the one habit
the one thing that has a meaningful
behavior change that impacts
what you get
it's your visibility you see you don't
get credit you don't get paid for and
you don't get graded on the things that
people can't see
in order for you to get what you deserve
you have to start being deliberate about
your visibility behavior that you've got
to start learning to do whether you're
shy
whether you're introverted whether
english is your second language it
doesn't matter you've got to learn how
to speak up you've got to learn how to
share your ideas you've got to learn how
to talk about your business you've got
to learn to talk about your dreams and
your goals and i know for many of you
that is one of the most terrifying
things in the world you hate being the
center of attention the idea of speaking
in a meeting at work and risking
sounding like you don't know what you're
talking about is really scary the idea
of asking for feedback from your boss or
asking for a raise really scary the idea
of going in and talking your professor
about adjusting your grade really scary
the idea of raising your hand i get it i
read your emails i see the comments but
you've got to understand that this is
the number one skill that you need
in order to increase your visibility
wherever it is that you need to increase
your visibility the world doesn't need
another perfect person
the world needs you
and you're trying your best
you're doing what you can
and you know i think it's really
important that you cut yourself a break
and that you stop thinking that you have
to be perfect there are going to be days
where you're an hour late to pick up
your kid and that's okay
there are going to be days when you
can't get to every email and that's okay
there are going to be days where you
feel so underwater and that's okay
you'll get through it you'll figure it
out and you've got to understand that
it's not about being perfect
it's about just being you and that means
that you got to be willing to start
before you're ready you got to be
willing to
do what i do every damn day which is
show up in my rollers or start a live
stream and disconnect myself or start it
and be talking and not even know that
i'm broadcasting
you've got to do that version in your
life or you're not going to get ahead
period so instead of doing what so many
of us do when we're broken up with and
we go i'm a loser i'm unlovable i'm not
good enough
what i want you to do instead is i want
you to put that opinion and judgment on
the relationship itself
that relationship that's over wasn't
good enough
wasn't worthy and wasn't the right fit
for love for you
do not take that on as an internal
judgment of yourself
make sure that when you're judging it
you're judging the relationship and how
it wasn't a good fit for you
you my friend are whole you my friend
are perfect how you are and yeah you may
have to change yeah yeah there's things
that you can do better now that you know
better yes there's baggage you got to
deal with but there's nothing wrong with
you there's just patterns that you need
to deal with that's it you'll get the
day
where you celebrate and that was
yesterday
and
you'll have that moment where you cannot
believe that you actually got into the
school that you wanted or you got the
job that you wanted or you found the
person that that really complements you
finally or that you got the raise that
you wanted or you built the house that
you've always dreamt of and then a funny
thing happens after you actually achieve
the dream
after you celebrate
life goes right back to the way that it
was
and for me what i'm present to is not
the fact that this talk show's actually
happening it's i'm focused on all the
work that i now need to do
in order to do the talk show as
powerfully as i can and i think
that
the point that i'm trying to make about
the fact that yeah you can achieve all
the things that you're going for but
i've even noticed already in just 24
hours like that the crazy rise in
emotion and excitement has already been
replaced with things are back to normal
that is exactly what psychologists talk
about when it comes to happiness because
happiness is not about achieving things
it's not about getting the result it's
about
how you
pursue the things
that you enjoy and why you're pursuing
them and so
the key to life and i'm seeing it happen
in my own life is not actually checking
the boxes
and getting all those things that you
dream about it's
how you go about living your life as
you're pursuing them because if i were
just going to like check the box and now
i'm done biggest goal of my life to have
a daytime talk show just achieve that
what do i have to look forward to
nothing if you've already achieved it
which is why it's so important for you
to
understand that the real meaning of
happiness is about how you show up every
day yes you should have big goals yes
you should have big dreams yes yes yes
and yes you should pursue them
don't ever think that quote making your
dreams come true is what actually makes
you happy because what actually makes
you happy is having those big dreams and
waking up every morning
and
doing a little something to push
yourself to make them happen it's about
the pursuit i think it's really
important for your personal boundaries
to use what i always talk about which is
empathy understand that anybody that's
acting out it doesn't excuse the
behavior it explains it and it also
allows you to separate yourself
emotionally that person is likely
miserable that person has a bad life
which is why they treat people badly and
so if you can start to really use
empathy to put it on them versus making
it that they are doing something to you
that can help you from getting hooked
emotionally if you start shifting the
dynamic and here's how you do it you do
it by being a fan what do i mean i talk
about this all the time if you google
mel robbins being a fan you'll probably
come up with like 10 different videos on
youtube about this philosophy it's a
philosophy about leading with
appreciation it's a philosophy about
cheering for other people publicly
because what happens when you cheer for
other people
is you naturally trigger the law of
reciprocity and even the biggest jerk
face even the biggest curmudgeon even
the biggest most competitive person on
the planet who might be competitive by
the way because she's paying for her
parents
nursing home bill
and she's feeling stressed out and she's
also divorced i mean who knows what's
driving this competitive nature maybe
it's a sense of scarcity and fear and
insecurity and so the opposite of
competition isn't more competition it's
connection
and you create connection
by cheering for people the majority of
people lack self-awareness at work
you get that
the person who's disrespecting you
likely doesn't even know what they're
doing
the person who's taking
his or her anger out on you
likely doesn't know how it's impacting
you you see when people do this when
they have these kind of toxic patterns
they've been getting away with them for
so long because nobody has had the
courage to cross check them verbally on
it and that's where you come in lucky
you you're in their life because your
purpose in their life is to be the one
person that has the courage to actually
sit down and have a candid conversation
about it so what are you going to do how
do you have that candid conversation
first of all try not to make them wrong
try not to come in and shame them and
tell them all the horrible things
they're doing because you'll immediately
create a situation where they're
defensive and if the research bears out
from harvard business school and they
actually had no idea that they were
doing it they might get defensive
the better way to do it the more
effective way to do it is to explain
how their behavior impacts you
and when you do that
most people are mortified
because most people are venting or are
disrespectful and they're not even
thinking about the impact it has
because nobody's ever told them you
gotta raise your own game
gotta raise your own game and so what is
the game that you play at work you gotta
get out of the head that it's all about
you
the best team members are always
thinking about how to make the team
better the best team members are loyal
to the team the best people to work with
are the ones that are in it together and
so in order for you
to get your toxic colleague to shift
behavior you gotta model it and here's
the interesting thing about the research
when people are working with co-workers
or on a team
where people collaborate and where you
have honest conversations
it creates what we call psychological
safety which basically just means i feel
safe working with you i know that if i
come to you with feedback you listen i
know that if i tell you how your
behavior is impacting me you'll actually
care i know that if you need help you'll
come to me and i know if i need help i
can come to you that's what
psychological safety means you're a safe
person and hopefully a fun person to
work with
so you've got to model that that means
you got to ask for support that means
you got to have direct collaborat direct
conversations and it means you got gotta
support your team members too and do you
realize
that when
you work with other people that do this
team members are 35 times more likely
to show visible commitment to your
success and they're 47 more likely when
you model it to work hard to build and
maintain your trust
so don't ever get resigned and thinking
that the way that you behave
won't impact how somebody else is
behaving around you one of the most
important things when you're in a
situation where the truth the facts are
that there is more on your plate than
one human being can effectively handle
on his or her own
there's a really important
moment where you have to surrender
to the chaos
that your life is for the next couple
weeks
things are going to change when summer
hits
but part of what i find personally
is that when i resist and i do resist
i resist what's actually happening when
that's not the way that i want things to
go
and so if you
start complaining or you start bringing
extra weight to all of the things that
are going on it's gonna
make it feel even more overwhelming
and if you can bring a sense of realism
to it so i call this and i think shawn
anchors the one that came up with this
this this term
realistic optimism
realistic optimism is a really powerful
mindset because
you're not just putting a sunny spin
on a crappy situation
you're being realistic about where you
are in your life right now
and you are
still
maintaining an optimistic point of view
and what that means is that you when
you're an optimist you believe that your
actions and your thoughts matter
you believe that you can handle what's
on your plate you believe that based on
your thoughts and your actions you can
positively affect the outcome of
whatever it is that you're dealing with
whether it's being wildly overwhelmed
because you're a single parent or
terrified because you just got a scary
health diagnosis
or you're spinning because somebody just
told you they don't want to be in a
relationship with you anymore whatever
it is that you're facing that's making
you feel
overwhelmed first start with how
important it is to be a realistic
optimist so there's a surrendering to
what's so but you're going to stay very
optimistic and positive and know that
everything that you think and do is in
your control and that when you know that
your behavior matters it gives you a
sense of empowerment that's proven by
research super duper important it's also
why
you can have a very hard life right now
and a very overwhelming life right now
and still be happy
because you know based on being a
realistic optimist that this period will
pass and you know that there are things
that you can think about and do that are
within your control often times when you
hit bottom you bounce
and that's where i think the power is
that you when the world feels upside
down you always have the power to make
it right when one chapter ends you
always have the power to write a new one
when you know you feel like nobody loves
you you have the power to learn how to
love yourself and if there's one thing
that covid 19 has done regardless of
whatever devastation it has caused in
your life is it has forced us all
to experience the great pause
and
i read that in a medium article and i
love that idea of a pause because i
think in 2020 our lives have gotten so
fast and so digital and
when you are forced to pause and get
present and to slow down
you are reminded
of what's actually important
and what's important is your health
what's important is your family and your
friends
what's important is whether or not you
are taking care of yourself and thinking
positive thoughts versus negative
thoughts the world gave us a gigantic
experiment
where we got to practice and get to
continue to practice the most important
skill in the planet which is emotional
resilience the ability to face hard
and actually be okay
the ability to face the uncertain
and redirect your attention on things
that you know that are certain but as is
the case in life you're always going to
be growing and when you hit new chapters
in your life
it's really important to be deliberate
and mindful
about the people that you spend time
with and who you surround yourself with
does that mean you gotta ditch your high
school friends absolutely not
but it might mean that you shouldn't
spend as much time
with them
it might mean that you should show up to
those friendships a little bit
differently and maybe they'll go a
little bit deeper and it definitely
means that based on where you are in
your life right now
that you should get more proactive about
surrounding yourself with a group of new
friends or current friends that are up
to the same kind of growth that you are
and i always talk about how you have the
power in your life always i know that
you may have your feelings hurt
i know you may
be angry or upset or frustrated i
certainly feel those things all the time
in my life but i want you to understand
that no matter what's going on you
always have the power because you can
choose what you think and what you do
next
you may not be able to control the way
that somebody treated you you may not be
able to control uh the number of
promotions that have passed you by you
may not be able to control whether or
not your boss is a jerk face or not to
you
but you can choose how you respond to
these things and that's where your power
is and this is a very important first
piece of advice by the way is that a lot
of times we start to feel the weight of
the overwhelm but we don't get out of
our heads and if you spend too much time
thinking about all the stuff that's
going on and you don't go through the
process of breaking it down and figuring
out what actually is important to you
and prioritizing what you're going to do
about it you're just going to continue
to feel heavier and heavier and heavier
it's more and more sunk i mean it's it's
a very very difficult thing to feel why
don't you like the size you're all
is it
okay
because i don't believe in losing weight
to be skinny
i believe in
getting healthy because of how it makes
you feel yeah so if you love the size
that you are and it's healthy you should
stay the size that you are
but
if you look in the mirror
and seeing your body the size that it is
gives you evidence to say i'm a piece of
or i'm unworthy what do you say to
yourself when you see yourself in the
mirror
all of those things tell me what is it
let's get it out of your head
and let's bring it to the light because
you know you feel comfortable saying
this to yourself
when you're alone don't you
i want you to say it out loud because
it's it's not
okay to say this stuff to yourself what
do you say to yourself that we're not
going to say anymore i'm disgusting i'm
disgusting what else
i like the way i look i hate the way
that i look i feel i hate the way that i
feel okay what do you want what do you
deserve
to feel good when they walk down the
street yes yes you do see i think at the
heart of this
i think at the heart of this is a belief
that you don't deserve
to feel that way
so who taught you to feel that that you
don't deserve it when did you start
saying that to yourself that you don't
deserve it holly
maybe when i was like
that's usually when it happens
so what i want you to do
is i want you to leave here and what
you're going to go to war against is not
your weight you're going to go to war
against the pattern in your head okay
because the longer you invalidate
yourself the less motivated you're going
to be to change yeah because you're
beating yourself down so we got to start
with not fixing you
you're not broken
you're perfect how you are holly you are
i know you don't feel that way but i
feel that way yeah
it's the pattern up here
that's broken yeah so we just want you
to have a zero tolerance policy for this
like i'm not worth it i don't deserve it
i'm a piece of this um all that no five
four three two one it's like an axe
you got that
and then you're going to come up what
can we say instead
i can do this i do that i can do this
but more important i think it needs to
be more heart-centered i deserve
to feel good yeah i deserve
to have what i want
watch me go get it
my own mind because it's not something
i'm used to yet is making up stories to
cling to the old way of life this is a
moment in time everyone please
this is the greatest gift
the greatest gift is this moment of
pause where you get in touch with what
you actually want and if you don't have
the skills
for crying out loud look around and take
an online course because if you need
skills
to prepare yourself for the thing that
you want get them right now
when you hit a moment in your life or
your work or your family where you feel
very overwhelmed
one of the most important things to not
do
is to not speed up
um i tend to be the kind of person that
when i get overwhelmed or i feel the
weight of a world on my shoulders or i
feel stuck i tend to start running into
a brick raw head first at about 50 miles
an hour
that is exactly what you should not do
you should slow down
you should slow down and you should
assess where you are
and you should bring that realistic
optimism
to doing some problem solving
and some planning
and some decluttering
in your very busy life in four three
four main categories okay
it's so important that you slow down and
realize that part of the overwhelm is
coming from the fact that you are too
busy
there is too much on your plate
there's probably a lot on your plate
that's the wrong things there are
probably things that you're thinking
about that are not important and that's
why once you slow down you also start to
think about being a realistic optimist
you also need to declutter and that's
where your friend mel robbins comes in
setting a quitting cut time isn't
something that i invented it's something
i stole from a professor at caltech
and the the
setting a quitting time habit is so
important it leverages something called
parkinson's law parkinson's law is a
phenomenon around time that basically
says this
anything that you have to get done
you will get done in the amount of time
that you give to it so let me just ask
you this if you think about your to-do
list if you have 10 hours today to work
on it how long is it going to take you
to get through it 10 hours
if you have 10 minutes to get through
the to-do list that you have how long is
it going to take you 10 minutes
because the things you need to do expand
or contract according to how much time
you have to give to it and so what i
want you to do right now because part of
your problem with your routine is you
don't have one you allow work to bleed
into your evening you allow work to just
constantly show up whenever the email
arrives and you're the one that has to
hit
reset on your routine so that you don't
allow your work to do that here's the
thing about morning routines i think
morning routine envy is a real thing
and
i do believe that a lot of people lie
about their morning routines
i think lying about your morning routine
is a real thing i think pretending you
have the perfect morning routine
is a real thing um
i'm
i'm about when i'm home i'm almost 80
in my morning routine i get it done
because it's super simple right so i
mean i think i need a simple one yes
and when i'm traveling
i almost never get the whole thing done
because there's too many excuses and so
i think the key to having a morning
routine and morning routines are
critical
because how you start your day has a
massive
proven impact on how your day turns out
there's one piece of research that i
think is really profound and this comes
from sean anchor i talked about this
yesterday but i'm gonna i'm gonna tell
you um this too susie
if you consume three minutes just three
minutes of negative news
of negative television
of negative emails maybe stressful
emails from work or stressful texts from
friends
you have more than a 50
chance eight hours later to say you had
a bad day
and the reason why is because of what
consuming that kind of information does
to your mind
it literally sets your mind
up to be on the lookout for things going
wrong
and so the reason why a morning routine
is is actually so important is because
number one
it determines what your priority for the
day is and we also know based on
research that your mood in the morning
it impacts your productivity all day
long everything that i have done since
since we launched a five-second rule
book was in reaction to things that were
coming to me so i never sat out and said
hey the five second rule audiobook has
been a complete uh like record breaker
we clearly have an audio audience let's
go pitch audible came to me which is
fantastic
um i never i i always dreamt about
having a talk show but i wasn't out
pitching one
sony came to me in fact the only reason
why we got into courses online courses
and we now have more than a half a
million people that have taken our
courses online
um
was because success magazine came to me
and said let's do a course together
remember i was there interviewing you
for it
oh that was i hated it because what i
discovered is i hate being told what to
do
and so
but that gave me the idea oh we should
do courses ourselves and so this pause
has made me stop and go well what do i
really want to do
and
the the truth is i want to go and make
the biggest possible impact that i can
and i want to collaborate with more
people
and
i want to do events
um
and i
i don't want to be the ceo i'm a
terrible leader horrible leader
the worst actually um because i'm
amazing at coaching i'm amazing at uh
creating i'm amazing at reacting i'm
terrible at managing people i'm terrible
at managing a project i have add i have
dyslexia
um
i'm a bulldozer when i get anxious
um
we kill each other if we were roommates
or business partners but but i think
understanding yourself
is really important and so there's a
couple things that i've decided number
one i'm going to consciously create the
next
chapter and what is that and i'm
um well i'm still in the middle of doing
it yeah but you're one of the events you
want to do these things you're talking
about yeah
yes
and i want to i want to collaborate more
with a wider audience of people
and i want to build a brand bigger than
mel robbins yep
i don't want it to just be me i want to
build a
platform based business that uh reaches
more people because here's the thing
that has got that got me through kind of
the loss of the talk show and the way
that i think about things that i hope
helps
um if you're listening you're kind of
struggling with something um
i believe and i went into the talk show
saying this to myself because there's a
99 chance based on the history of people
that have tried to have a daytime talk
show that was going to fail
and
i went in there saying
this i'm not doing this because i expect
to have a successful talk show i'm going
to put a thousand percent into it so
that i have no regrets and i wouldn't
change a thing
but i'm going into this because i know
that there is a skill
a person or an experience i am meant to
have
that will help me
for the next chapter that i can't see
coming now i've got a special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the good deed
of the day this is something new i
believe that you're built to serve and
it feels so good to do something nice
for somebody else so good deed of the
day put down in the comments one thing
that you need help with that you're
working on you'd love some support or
guidance on and then two go comment on
somebody else's comment and give them
some love give them some support give
them some encouragement maybe give them
some connections try to help them solve
that problem even if it's saying i
believe in you that one little bit of
encouragement can be the difference
between somebody quitting and continuing
on so the good deed of the day in the
comments below write down one thing that
you need help on that you're struggling
with that you're working on and then
part two is go give love to somebody
else in the comments too and let them
know that you believe in them as well
when you uh face a scary financial
situation and i have been there i have
been more than eight hundred thousand
dollars in debt with liens on my house
and a car that's about to be repossessed
and a credit card and a banking card
that had no money on it
i distinctly remember two very low
moments
one being standing at the local grocery
store knowing there was no money in the
account and uh handing the card over and
just praying in that moment that somehow
there would be some technical glitch and
it would go through
and when it didn't i remember feeling
the just ugh shame
of standing there with a pile of
groceries and people lined up behind me
and uh
i had an excuse ready i kind of cocked
my head and looked kind of confused and
was like well that's strange because it
just worked at the gas station that was
a lie
and then i said i uh we'll be right back
i'm going to go out to my car and get my
other credit card and i walked out of
there got in that car and drove away
and the other one was when our daughter
was doing town soccer and we did not
have the money to
pay the 125 dollar registration fee and
i was too embarrassed to email
and uh tell the coach and um so we just
pulled her it's awful when you are broke
and it's awful when you can't pay your
bills and it is a level of stress
that is hard to describe unless you've
experienced it
one of the things
that will keep you in that death spiral
is if you keep a mindset that says i'm a
bad person because of this
you may have made bad financial
decisions but that doesn't make you a
bad person so you have to separate the
situation you're in from what you say
about yourself as a person
i made tremendous mistakes financially
that's why we were in the situation we
were in my husband made bad mistakes
that's why we were in the situation we
were in also most entrepreneurial
ventures fail
and so when you just look at the numbers
if you're going to go play a big game
the odds are you're going to fail it
doesn't mean
you're a failure that's the separation
that you want to make and so the key to
moving forward is
using this moment where you hit rock
bottom because when you hit rock bottom
an interesting thing happens
you hit something solid when you hit the
ground and you also come in touch with
something solid within yourself
you access that by having a reckoning
with yourself and saying
all right
what am i responsible for
what am i going to learn from this
and what behaviors am i going to change
and here's the good news there is so
much financial education out there
there is so much information
just make a commitment to yourself that
you are going to learn how to get out of
debt you're going to follow an expert in
financial
literacy and then getting out of debt
and you're going to do exactly what they
say
because you're clearly not an expert in
it and you're going to watch the
behaviors that got you in trouble in the
first place and you're gonna watch them
like a shark and you're gonna interrupt
them five four three two one use my five
second rule to stop the behavior and
redirect yourself and do absolutely
everything that the experts tell you to
do
because you can get out of debt
you can save money you can work four
jobs if you have to you can learn how to
be responsible with money and you're
only going to do it if you use this
moment as a way to
have a reckoning with yourself admit
what you're responsible for
do the work to figure yourself out and
follow the advice of the experts that's
the way i did it that's the way you're
going to do it too if you want some
awesome motivation from oprah winfrey
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there all of us
are seeking the same thing you're here
at this fabulous school
and will go out into the world and each
pursue based upon what you believe your
talents are